see what I've realized nowadays
especially with women I feel like a lot
of them they they want they want you to
accept them how they already are they
don't want to grow more you know what
I'm trying to say so that's good that's
good to know I also started listening to
these like online stuff right and all
these women would talk about how they
wanted like one percent of income men
well that's my dad yeah and that's
that's like a lot of my brothers are in
that category so I'm like they wouldn't
even look twice at you and it's nothing
to do with their looks it's like the way
they carry themselves and the way they
act and the fact that like they have no
respect for men and so to me when I
first started getting online it was just
more like hey this is where I grew up
and you would not get in the door like
yeah